[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
facebook and other social media
companies are under growing pressure
from the biden administration to stop
the spread of vaccine misinformation
we spoke exclusively with facebook ceo
and co-founder that's mark zuckerberg
about the platform's efforts to handle
this issue and what is facebook doing to
protect its own employees amid this
pandemic
facebook just announced last week you
guys were planning to go back into the
office on in october and now you've just
delayed it till january 2022.
tell us why
yeah that that's right i mean i i think
the numbers that we're seeing around
this delta variant with kovid
um are pretty concerning and they're
growing and it just underscores i think
the importance of um you know everyone
getting vaccinated to help get this
under control will you lose your job if
you're not vaccinated well we're going
to allow people to work remotely i also
think that there are some health
exemptions but overall
we want to make sure that our employee
population especially the people are in
the office you know in the open floor
plan that we have um are both safe
themselves and um contributing to a safe
community and how are you guys mark
gonna manage it because you know we've
seen the honor system does not work
i think that this is an important
question um and you know within our
employee base we we do
require that our employees are honest
with us if they if they lie to the
company about any number of things um
then
you know that that can cause
serious issues and and we we terminate
people for that um
but
i i don't know that there's a any
bulletproof solution to this i want to
talk to you about covet misinformation
on your platform that's a really big
topic these days i want to know
specifically what you and your team are
doing
to fight against it sure
this is a very important topic and and
you know facebook is taking i i think
it's been an unprecedented effort to
help encourage people to get vaccinated
to promote authoritative information
about covenant in the vaccines and to
fight and take down misinformation so
you know millions of people have taken
their first step to getting their
vaccine through a vaccine finder tool
that we've built
at the top of facebook and instagram
we've put over the last year basically
links to this coronavirus information
hub sharing authoritative information
from government officials as well as
trusted community leaders
billions of people have visited it in
terms of fighting misinformation we've
taken down more than 18 million pieces
of misinformation you know the numbers
you talk about are good uh i i think
everybody agrees that facebook has done
a lot
to combat misinformation but we still
don't know how much misinformation has
been shared on your platform how many
people have viewed it how many people
have acted upon that facebook seems very
reluctant to share those numbers how
come
well i think to some degree there are
um
also different definitions that people
have over what misinformation is where a
lot of the the stuff that's actually the
hardest for us to um to to really
address
is not what i would call misinformation
but instead another category that i
would call
hesitancy when you were first thinking
about getting your vaccine you probably
had questions around you know which
vaccine is the most effective for you
and your family and in some of these
times when people ask these questions or
or is this safe yet should i wait a
while um that's not misinformation uh
but it's it's certainly um you know
contributing to an environment where
people are asking questions about the
safety of vaccines i don't think we
should ban it um but i i do think that
that's a big part of the discourse at
this point and certainly causes people
to ask questions about whether they want
to get vaccinated so from a public
health perspective it may not be the
most positive thing i almost think
though mark it's more than hesitancy
discourse there have been some things
that are just blatantly not true
recent studies by northwestern and
harvard say those who are most reliant
on facebook for information have
substantially lower vaccination rates
than those who rely on other sources
does that surprise you there are people
who share misinformation and that's why
i said that we took down and have taken
down more than 18 million pieces of
harmful misinformation about this so you
know if you look around the world in
different countries
right different countries i think are
doing better and worse on getting their
citizens vaccinated and you know the us
i think has has a specific issue on this
people use facebook and social media all
across the world so if this were
primarily a question about social media
then i think you'd see that being the
effect in all of these countries where
people use it but i think that there's
something that's unique in our ecosystem
here whether it's you know some of the
political leaders and or some of the the
media figures that i think is different
than what we're seeing across a lot of
europe or across a a lot of other
countries that are leading to to higher
levels of this so i i don't think
pinning this on social media primarily
is is is accurate
now since our interview with mark
zuckerberg facebook released new new
numbers rather on misinformation in its
second quarter community standards
enforcement report now they now say more
than 20 million pieces of covid 19
misinformation have been removed since
the start of this pandemic through june
in our next hour we'll talk to mark
zuckerberg he will show us how virtual
reality could transform the way we work
remotely is that a virtual you gail
that's a virtual me and a virtual market
which is why he agreed to do this
interview by the way you know i give him
credit for saying look i want to talk
about this you can
you can talk about anything and you know
i will i will answer the questions as
best as i can but he didn't sit down to
talk about uh misinformation but it is
still an issue and you know they're kind
of related because the virtual office
may be what we go to if misinformation
on vaccines means the virus continues to
spread well just to study tony from
harvard in northwestern it's very
interesting i think that's very
interesting that the people who rely on
facebook
are are less vaccinated than other
people and it's a very small group of
people that are putting out the
misinformation but it's getting out and
i think it's frustrating that facebook
doesn't really give the numbers on that
yeah and you know they're they're such a
huge company they're so talented they're
so smart it seems like we could get that
it is also a very old problem right the
misinformation can travel around the
world by the time truth puts on its
pants yeah